[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue à tous dans ce
nouveau numéro du 7-8 l'hebdo l'émission
de la rédaction pour revenir sur
l'actualité départementale de la semaine
voici les titres de ce vendredi 3 mars
les vacances scolaire s'achève à
guyancourt la ville proposé de
nombreuses activités aux plus jeunes
durant cette période de repos comme la
rénovation de l'espace point jeunes une
nouvelle décoration du lieu qui a duré
toute la semaine elle pourrait durer
elle plusieurs semaines la grève des
cheminots dans les transports en commun
si rien n'est encore acté les syndicats
devraient mener une action longue et
dure après les annonces du gouvernement
pour réformer la sncf
axel personne responsable cgt cheminots
attrape sera notre invité dans le reste
de l'actualité retour sur l'inauguration
à trappes d'un laboratoire dédié aux
nanotechnologies ou encore la ville de
plaisir en pleine mutation urbaine
les vacances se terminent donc ce
week-end pour les élèves saint
quentinois et des centres d'accueil pour
les jeunes ont encore fait le plein
pendant ses vacances dans les communes
de l'agglomération c'est le cas
notamment à vue en cours avec un
programme chargé activités sportives
mais aussi manuel reportage de nicolas
d'andré il avait une semaine pour tout
changer redécoré le point jeunes de la
république à guyancourt une activité
manuelle proposé à la quarantaine
d'adolescents accueilli en moyenne
pendant les vacances pour une eau et
shayne 11 ans apporte les dernières
touches de peinture sur le bar j'aime
bien peindre et les orcs manière aussi
et donner un petit coup de jeune au
point jeunes ça fait pas de mal je
trouve que c'est mieux de venir ici que
de rester chez soi super mario sonic une
fresque conçue en partie par dounia et
raffaella elle peaufine une autre
fresque destiné aux studios de musique
des habitués de cette structure pour les
jeunes de 11 à 15 ans chez soi et ben on
reste assis en train de regarder la télé
rien faire est ici pas ya plein de
choses à faire
si je reste chez moi je vais m'ennuyer
et
ici au moins on s'amuse ce type de point
jeunes une tradition dans la politique
jeunesse de guyancourt accessible à tous
les adolescents munis d'une carte
d'adhésion pour un tarif de 10 euros par
an le but est de créer du lien social
entre les jeunes
un certain nombre de jeunes qui se
trouvent sans activité parce que le
centre de loisirs ça les intéresse pas
plus forcément parce qu'ils sont plus
grand donc c'est de proposer des
activités au plus haut plus âgé il ya
donc c'est proposer un petit différend
tchéquie pas votre langue centre de
loisirs qui correspondent plus à leur
tranche d'âge et qui se retrouvent pas
tout seul pendant les vacances quoi
suite à une consultation un espace
jeunes devraient ouvrir en juin prochain
dans le coeur du quartier villa roi il
permettra d'accueillir des guyancourt
toi âgés de 15 à 25 ans et la fin des
vacances riment aussi avec retour pour
les plus chanceux ceux qui sont allés au
ski le week-end s'annonce sans
perturbation majeure en ile-de-france
selon bison futé
l samedi et dimanche sont classées vert
seuls quelques ralentissements sont à
prévoir au péage de saint arnoult en
yvelines en fin d'après midi samedi
du côté des transports en commun pas de
perturbations importantes non plus à
prévoir excepté des horaires de trains
est modifiée pour les lignes n ai eu à
cause des travaux du grand paris express
précisions sur transilien.com des
transports fortement perturbée dans les
prochaines semaines c'est en revanche le
scénario qui se dessine après les
annonces du gouvernement sur la réforme
du rail français fin du statut des
cheminots transformation de la sncf en
société nationale à capitaux publics
aient recours aux ordonnances pour aller
plus vite la confrontation avec les
syndicats s'annonce rude pour en parler
axel personne responsable de la cgt
cheminots à trappes
bonsoir bonsoir les syndicats n'ont pas
encore décidé du rapport de forces qu'il
souhaitait installer avec le
gouvernement il ya une réunion
intersyndicale prévue le 15 mars
est ce que ça veut dire qu'il ya une
hésitation sur sur la méthode que vous
souhaitez employés peut-être des
divergences aussi entre les syndicats ce
dont il faut être assurée c'est en tout
cas la très grande détermination des
cheminots mais aussi je le souligne
d'associations d'usagers qui nous
rejoignent sur ce combat a opposé une
résistance à la hauteur de ces attaques
donc il ya une interfédérale en effet
nationale qui va se réunir le 15 mars
est elle déterminée
en fonction des remontées des terrains
des différentes équipes quelle forme on
donnera à la grève dans l'unité la plus
large que possible dans tous les
chantiers mais la confrontation va venir
si le gouvernement ne recule pas ça sur
les assurés liés il ya une journée de
grève déjà prévu c'est le 22 mars elle
englobe l'ensemble delà de la fonction
publique les syndicats vont y participer
cgt cheminots notamment initialement
quand même lundi après les annonces du
gouvernement il y avait un ton un peu
plus élevées envers le gouvernement plus
percutant aujourd'hui on a l'impression
que le ton semble un peu s'abaisser
s'assagir est ce que ça veut dire que
vous laisser la chance aux négociations
et aux discussions est ce que il ya
peut-être déjà des annonces du
gouvernement en votre faveur
aujourd'hui la seule chose qu'elles se
bornent le gouvernement c'est d'annoncer
une phase de pseudo concertation qui
vont s'étaler entre mars et avril
mais en tout cas sur le fond de la
réforme le gouvernement reste ferme et a
annoncé sa volonté très clairement de
procéder par voie d'ordonnancé à des
attaques d'une ampleur historique contre
le chemin de fer et aussi contre la
qualité des dessertes et il va donc
falloir qu'on ait repose une riposte à
la hauteur et ça en tout cas c'est ce
qu'ils sont en train de se passer
maintenant dans tous les chantiers dans
tout le territoire on en train de
tourner et organiser des réunions pour
préparer les mobilisations et les amener
à la guerre ça veut dire la guerre donc
ça veut dire que vous vous annoncer
ouvertement peut-être aux yvelinois qui
vont avoir des semaines compliquées de
la faute du gouvernement
ça pourrait durer plusieurs semaines
vous par exemple à trappes quel serait
pour vous un bon mouvement de grève pour
faire face à ces annonces du
gouvernement
ce n'est pas que j'ai pas envie de
répondre à la question mais c'est que
pour l'instant on n'a pas encore décidé
c'est justement ce que je vous disais on
va organiser des réunions dans tous les
ateliers en tout cas l'action la guerre
est déclarée
mais en tout cas c'est le gouvernement
qui la déclare la guerre ce n'est pas
nous qui la déclare ont en tout cas on
va relever le défi et c'est sûr qu'on va
pas se laisser marcher sur les pieds
comme ça est ce que en tant que syndicat
va regarder aussi les opinions qui les
sondages par exemple qui semble pour
l'instant il faut toujours se méfier des
sondages on a bien conscience mais qui
sont pour l'instant plutôt soutenir la
réforme du gouvernement est ce que vous
regardez ça aussi pour voir si si
l'opinion va vous suivre on le sait
c'est c'est important quand on se lance
dans une telle manifestation greinke en
premier lieu ce qui importe avant tout
c'est de susciter l'adhésion de ceux qui
vont partir au combat c'est à dire donc
dans ce cas présent les cheminots après
évidemment la question savez comment on
arrive à élargir le conflit et obtenir
le soutien de la jarne large majorité de
la population est comment va faire
pouvoir s'y reconnaître ça c'est la
deuxième question dont vous avez essayé
lisez aussi les oui tout à fait et en
plus y'a des associations d'usagers qui
ne sont pas dupes des annonces
gouvernementales notamment sur la
question des fermetures des petites
lignes
le gouvernement prétend donc renoncer à
la fermeture des petites lignes
mais en même temps annonce que
finalement la responsabilité de ces
petites îles vont revenir aux régions
dans les finances sont déjà exsangues et
qui ont donc pas les moyens de les
maintenir en l'état donc les
associations d'usagers ne s'y trompe pas
plusieurs élus d'ailleurs dans la
ruralité et cite aucun nom du hainaut
rejoint n'auront d'ailleurs dans ce
combat vous dit sa peine recul a par
exemple ses annonces sur les petites
lignes s'est passé pas pour vous
satisfaire c'est plutôt à leur tout à
fait oui parce que le gouvernement a
très clairement qu'il reconnaissait n'a
pas lancé je maintiens je finance les
petites ce qu'il appelle les petites
lignes ce qu'il annonce c'est dire bon
bah je vais renvoyer la responsabilité
aux régions qui ensuite si elle veut les
maintenir prendront les financements
nécessaires mais en tout cas l'état
annonce progressivement son
désengagement de deux de ses lignes là
et ça les associations d'usagers ne s'y
trompent pas et de nombreuses
associations aussi d'élus locaux dans la
ruralité notamment ne s'y trompe pas non
plus et c'est pour cette raison qu'on
les reverra à eux aussi dans la
manifestation du 22 mars qui râlent
largement au delà des cheminots parce
que ce qui se joue là finalement c'est
pas qu'un bras de fer entre les
cheminots et la direction du groupe
public ferroviaire c'est un bras de fer
assez globale finalement entre le monde
du travail et les voeux patronat et le
gouvernement de manière générale qui
était en train dé la théorisation se
prononcent cheminots il espère faire
kahn est aujourd'hui un secteur qui
s'opposent qui résistent à leur lit en
fait jean toi juste des mots à la
hauteur des attaques tout simplement et
le gouvernement il ne s'y trompe pas il
espère infligé une défaite aujourd'hui
aux cheminots de manière à pouvoir
s'attaquer aujourd'hui à tout le reste
du monde du travail notamment avec la
réforme des retraites qui a annoncé pour
l'année prochaine espère ici marque et
donc un coût politique pour assommer un
c'est même s'il lui reste encore une
fois les sondages semble pas en tout cas
critiqué cesser ces ambitions là ça
dépend de quel sondage vous toutefois
s'en méfier des sondages globalement on
a quand même l'impression que le
gouvernement et soutenue bah disons ça
on le verra une fois que le combat il
sera lancé il ya un tas de mouvements
aujourd'hui dans le passé aujourd'hui ou
le gouvernement semblait avoir la main
dans l'opinion et finalement a perdu ce
qu'on appelle la bataille de l'opinion
ça c'est arrivé à plusieurs reprises et
nous on va s'y employer évidemment parce
qu'il faut bien que les voyageurs qui
sont avant tout des salariés qu'on nous
comprenne c'est qu'aujourd'hui ce qui se
joue là c'est une question de rapport de
force global entre les salariés et le
gouvernement le gouvernement veut
s'attaquer à nous veut s'attaquer à nos
conditions de travail pour faire une
démonstration et metropcs à l'ensemble
du monde du travail c'est ça qui est en
train de se jouer
c'est pas juste une question du statut
des cheminots ou les justes actuelle va
peut-être en dire un mot est ce que vous
pensez que le gouvernement parce que
tout le monde se focalise là-dessus
c'est facile aussi peut-être
médiatiquement mais ce que vous pensez
que le gouvernement va reculer sur cette
question là sur cette problématique du
statut des cheminots se serait pas la
première fois que le gouvernement s'en
prend à des cheminots et ce serait pas
la première fois que les cheminots ont
remporté une victoire sociale parce que
de tout ça vous y croyez pas ce qu'on a
l'impression que c'est un peu la ligne
rouge du gouvernement que c'est le point
qui souhaite absolument mettre en avant
ou en tout cas dans la communication qui
en est fait aujourd'hui de cette réforme
parce que vous pensez que le
gouvernement est évidemment fait le
choix un peu stratégique de mettre en
avant avant tout la question du statut
des cheminots
même si il ya énormément d'aspects dans
cette réforme qu'il faut absolument
prendre en compte et le statut des
cheminots d'ailleurs le rapport spinetta
qui assure le rapport spinetta voilà qui
en parle justement alors il leur apporte
pin étant rappelle que c'est leur
rapport qu'il avait commandé le
gouvernement et qui s'évase et là dessus
pour ensuite proposer cette forme est
d'ailleurs le rapport spinetta le
rapport spinetta d'ailleurs dit bilingue
ce n'est pas le statut d'ailleurs qui
est la cause des problèmes du chemin de
fer dire il le dit assez clairement on
peut le reconnaître ce qu'il explique de
façon assez cynique que je trouve dans
le rapport spi l'état c'est que le
statut empêche aujourd'hui le groupe
public ferroviaire de notamment se
séparer jusqu'à 5000 salariés aussi
facilement que dans d'autres secteurs
privés parce qu'en effet le licenciement
a regroupé dans le chemin de fer est
prévu n'est qu'un nom uniquement qu'à
défaut un peu compliqué mais est prévu
l'équipement quatre fautes si on commet
des fautes bon ben on peut être licencié
comme dans n'importe quelle entreprise
sauf que les procédures de licenciement
collectif de départs volontaires ou de
rupture conventionnelle collective ne
sont pas prévues par ce statut
il explique donc assez tranquillement
que dans le cadre d'une privatisation
ce statut va empêcher donc ce qui
pourrait récupérer ses salariés de les
licencier assez facilement et qu'il faut
donc impérativement mettre fin à ça
c'était sur sept générations à venir
le gouvernent
prévoit justement quand même des
garanties en lien avec les difficultés
de votre métier ce que c'est de nature à
vous rassurer ça si le statut est amené
à disparaître des garanties pour
reconnaître aussi c'est un métier
compliqué en fait la meilleure garantie
qui pour cette encore vagues la
meilleure garantie qui pourrait nous
apporter et qui pourrait que vous tentez
beaucoup de monde mais ça ne suffira pas
parce que rencontrent enfin y'a pas que
la question du statut à la question
vraiment de l'avenir notamment des
dessertes de la fixation des prix des
billets il ya plein de questions qui
rentre en compte derrière mais sur la
question du statut
nous on est porteur d'un projet
d'égalité c'est à dire qu'on veut que
tous ceux qui travaillent au chemin de
fer aujourd'hui bénéficier du même
statut
le gouvernement il veut impérativement
suivre la stratégie qui en cours dans
plusieurs secteurs de l'industrie on
commence introduire plusieurs statuts
différents dans le même collectif de
travail des intérimaires d'un côté des
gens c'est d'élever legend of conditions
du code du travail commençait absolument
créer une inégalité au sein du collectif
de travail et ça évidemment va s'y
opposer et on va pas dû se limiter à
défendre ceux qui ont déjà statut comme
moi aujourd'hui mais on va absolument se
battre pour les générations à venir
parce que je vais vous dire une chose et
je pense aujourd'hui à tous nos
retraités aujourd'hui qui ont mené les
combats pour qu'on ait ce statut qu'on
ait aujourd'hui nous ne serons pas la
génération qui aura vendu la génération
à venir ça de sorte que pour pouvoir se
regarder dans la glace on va mener le
combat être allé au nord à la hauteur du
combat de nos aînés est ce que vous
comprenez aussi l'argument de certains
de dire que par exemple on reprend ce
statut mais d'autres points de la sncf
que tout ça a été créé dans la première
moitié du 20e siècle et que finalement
c'est assez facile de dire ça mais c'est
aussi très juste que le monde a beaucoup
évolué et que du coup la sncf doit aussi
évoluer peut-être le statut des
cheminots qu'est ce que vous répondez à
cet argument là il tombe de ce bon sens
fait ce que lapiro répondre ce que je
peux répondre c'est qu'en fait le statut
des cheminots pour ceux qui le
connaissent en fait le problème c'est
que beaucoup de gens ne le connaissent
pas vraiment il ya des gens vous savez
qui pensent encore que le statut des
cheminots il ya des gens mais c'est la
beauté qui la prive de charbon j'ai déjà
entendu des gens qui pensent que dans la
crypte de l'église de quoi se restaurer
le statut a évolué énormément en fait
depuis la première version qui date
d'avant la sncf il n'a pas cessé
d'évoluer
le licenciement c'est un point sur
lequel la cgt ne veut pas bouger mais en
fait c'est ce que les cheminots non
parce que ces éléments de protection
face à l'arbitraire patronal en fait
c'est pas quelque chose dont on a honte
c'est un acquis dont est extrêmement
fière et aujourd'hui tous les salariés
aujourd'hui qu'ils subissent
l'arbitraire patronal dans l'eure
dans leur chantier dans leurs ateliers
en fait ils voudraient la même chose et
a donc il n'est pas question aujourd'hui
pour nous d'y renoncer et je lance un
message aujourd'hui à tous les salariés
qui souffrent dans leur lieu de travail
que s'ils veulent la même chose que nous
ils marcheront avec nous le 22 mars et
ils seront à nos côtés parce que s'ils
veulent abattre est vrai privé des
sociétés ils seront à nos côtés dans la
rue le 22 mars et dans la grève avec
nous une dernière réflexion mais très
importante évidemment c'est en lien avec
cette réforme c'est l'ouverture à la
concurrence des de l'adieu du rail
français selon les directives
européennes qui va s'étaler dans le
temps de 2019 jusqu'au début des années
2000 30 à peu près est ce que finalement
avec cette concurrence qui sera
forcément qui va arriver dans quelques
années est ce que c'est pas non plus
responsable de la part du gouvernement
de vouloir modifier un peu plus le
statut des cheminots par exemple parce
qu'on sait qu'il ya peut-être un
opérateur allemand qui va arriver avec
des conditions beaucoup plus souple et
qui va du coup faire beaucoup de tort à
la sncf puisque il n'est pas bon
d'anticiper ça mais en fait on peut
rencontrer facilement cette question
c'est que le statut des cheminots quand
il a été gagné notamment par les grandes
grèves notamment dans les années 20
quand il a été étendu il sncf n'existait
pas non la sncf n'existait pas à
l'époque c'était six compagnies privées
qui se partageaient les réseaux à les
vaincre
et à l'époque les cheminots des
différentes compagnies se sont unis pour
bagarrer et imposer ensemble les mêmes
conditions travail pour tous c'est ce
qui a servi de précurseur aux
conventions collectives dont 94 % des
salariés bénéficient aujourd'hui et
c'est pour ça que ça rend absolument
malades aujourd'hui nos adversaires
c'est parce que ses statuts la ont servi
de précurseur des avancées sociales pour
tous les salariés et je finis avec un
exemple assez concret je prends par
exemple exemple des congés payés les
cheminots elle avait obtenu un peu avant
les grandes grèves de 1936 et dans les
grèves de 1936 les autres salariés
disaient les cheminots et des congés
payés les emplois du métro parisien
n'ont eu et nous voulons la même chose
nous annonçait du coup que vous êtes
entre guillemets des précurseurs et
cassis votre mouvement est important
social on pourra avoir un mouvement
social beaucoup plus important en france
cinq ans après mai 68 vous avez l'air
très engagé je mets ça on suppose et ça
on verra bien mais en tout cas et les
ingrédients qui permettent de le penser
parce qu'à pas que les cheminées
aujourd'hui qui sont attaqués
aujourd'hui à des grèves extrêmement
forte je pense notamment à air france où
la grève est extrêmement suivi sur la
question des salaires
il ya des grèves dans la métallurgie les
étudiants se mobilisent partiellement et
commence à se mobiliser sur des
questions de sélection à l'université
les fonctionnaires sont dans l'action
donc évidemment aujourd'hui
mécontentement général qui en train de
s'exprimer et si les cheminots peuvent
en prendre la tête et cristallisé ce
mécontentement aggloméré de dos on a à
faire on peut en avoir le gouvernement
aura de quoi trembler on va suivre ça de
près puisque on rappelle qu'à 50 ans et
binya plusieurs gares sncf il y en a
cinq sur le bassin de saint quentin en
yvelines merci axel personnes d'avoir
répondu à toutes ses questions je
rappelle que vous êtes le représentant
de la cgt cheminots à trappes
merci encore et bon week-end des
perturbations encore et toujours cette
fois ci à cause de paris-nice la célèbre
course cycliste partira des yvelines
dimanche et pourrait entraîner la
fermeture de plusieurs routes sur le
secteur de saint quentin en yvelines va
entraîner d'ailleurs là la fermeture de
plusieurs routes ont fait le point avec
mélanie police après bois d'arcy l'an
dernier c'est au tour de chatou
d'accueillir la course au soleil
135 km à travers les yvelines avant de
rejoindre les hauts-de-seine un départ
fictif jusqu'à saint germain en laye et
à la sortie de saint germain en laye un
départ réel pour aller sur sur
villepreux sur ben sur les mais nul et
on va les chercher toutes les toutes les
côtes qui sont qui sont qui sont dans
les yvelines dont certains
connaissent notamment la côte de 17
tours ans on va les chercher à coups de
boules et les trous on va aller chercher
la coupe de châteaufort mais côté stèle
jacques anquetil donc ça parle aussi des
mots sont des endroits qui parle et un
retour sur saint quentin en yvelines
des difficultés de circulation seront à
prévoir la course entraînera des
fermetures quatre communes saint
quentinois sont concernés villepreux
magny les hameaux voisins le bretonneux
et montigny le bretonneux 154 coureurs
seront au départ de cette première étape
une étape qui devrait sourire aux
sprinteurs l'an dernier c'était arnaud
démare qui s'était imposé
mesurer l infiniment petit une activité
désormais possible la trappe avec
l'inauguration mardi du nouvel institut
ellen nanotech en présence de la
secrétaire d'état auprès du ministre de
l'économie et delphine génie stefan
installé dans les locaux du laboratoire
national d'essai et de métrologie
cet institut va permettre de faire
preuve de progrès s'est excusé moi nos
connaissances sur les nanotechnologies
aurélie ronces pour les détails voici un
microscope à force atomique métrologique
cet outil de pointe unique en france
fait partie des équipements du nouvel
institut ellen nanotech intégré au sein
du laboratoire national d'essai et de
métrologie
l'institut est en charge de la
réalisation des références à l'échelle
du nanomètre
il a notamment comme objectif de
développer les nanotechnologies vous
avez des applications par exemple sur
les écarts autonettoyante n'ai plus
besoin de nettoyer vos carreaux vous
avez des textiles qui ne semblent pas
mauvais parce qu'ils sont anti bactérien
vous avez des applications dans la santé
extrêmement importante
par exemple dans le traitement de
certains cancers
depuis plus de dix ans où elle est née
cette équipe de recherche travaillent
sur les nanomatériaux et les nano
dispositif une activité en plein essor
appelé à jouer un rôle important dans le
monde de demain
c'est absolument clé pour l'industrie et
en particulier toute une série
d'industries innovantes dans le domaine
du semiconducteur dans le monde aussi
dans le domaine alimentaire
pharmaceutique puisque les nanomatériaux
sont de plus en plus utilisés dans
l'industrie pour leurs propriétés
particulières une nouvelle technologie
source d'inquiétude d'où l'utilité de ce
nouvel institut sont des particules tout
petit qui peuvent franchir les barrières
biologiques de façon avec des propriétés
tout à fait un
diable et donc il faut mieux les
connaître mieux les caractérise et c'est
ce qu'on va faire ici objectif pour
l'institut ellen nanotech devenir un
opérateur de référence au niveau
national mais aussi international à
plaisir les travaux de requalification
de la place de l'église saint pierre ont
débuté cinq mois de chantier pour
réhabiliter le mur qui sépare la place
et le parc du château de plaisir la
maire de la ville était l'invité du
journal mercredi soit extrait c'est une
place qui a beaucoup bougé à travers les
siècles puisqu'on a retrouvé les
documents qui nous ont permis de voir
que le mur du château s'est déplacé au
coeur au cours du temps mais aujourd'hui
c'est une continuité par rapport aux
travaux que nous avons fait sur l'église
il ya quelques années ou 7 millions
d'euros étaient investis dans cette
église qui a été refaite complètement
parce que c'était une église qui allait
s'effondrer et donc suite à ça il était
question de refaire la place de l'église
pas tellement pour l'agrandir mais
surtout pour lui redonner je dirais une
logique de visibilité par rapport au
parc du château et surtout le château du
xviiie qui n'étaient pas visibles
oui parce que le mur était quelque chose
qui était un rempart physalies du parc
d'aujourd'hui on va le refaire permettre
l'insertion des personnes en situation
de handicap grâce au travail
c'est l'objectif de l'association delos
ap soixante dix huit la structure
dispose de deux établissements et
services d'aidé par le travail sur le
département des yvelines
aussi appelée esat de réelle entreprise
adaptée pour les travailleurs reportage
le travail se fait en équipe
nettoyez préparer et séchez les boîtes
en plastique qui seront ensuite utilisés
pour le vrac alimentaire et l'impression
d'être dans une entreprise classique
pourtant les travailleurs sont en
situation de handicap
ils sont plus de 150 dans cet
établissement spécialisé pour la plupart
ils sont polyvalents voir
multicompétence c'est à dire que ils
peuvent travailler dans cet atelier
sur un process spécifiques de lavage de
boîte mais ils peuvent aller dans un
autre atelier après pour faire autre
chose dans cette structure près d'une
trentaine de métiers sont proposés de la
blanchisserie avec une machine qui
repasse elle même les chemises
ou de la sous traitance industrielle
pour des missions de conditionnement ou
de la préparation de commandes
votre objectif c'est de faire en sorte
que quand ils sortent de les at il y ait
peu de différence entre ce qu'ils ont
vécu à les ath et ce qu'il pourrait
vivre dans une entreprise dite normale
pour faciliter l'insertion
professionnelle des travailleurs
l'établissement est aussi doté d'un
espace médico-social sept personnes
présentes pour accompagner et répondre à
des besoins parfois spécifiques qu'on
est quand même un accompagnement adapté
de la personne donc oui c'est qu'on va
prendre à temps avec la personne quand
ça va pas bien pour comprendre pourquoi
swaps et sur le plan personnel mais
aussi le plan de travail du sherlock
collègues 35 heures de travail par
semaine et une rémunération égale 1 1
smic
une fois l'ensemble des allocations
additionner 24 établissements de ce
genre sont présents sur le département
des yvelines pour un taux d'insertion
professionnelle inférieur à 5% après
trois ans de rebondissements l'horizon
du centre nautique de maurepas s
éclaircit la ville et les communes d'el
en cours et de coignières ont choisi de
s'associer pour avancer sur le projet en
piscine intercommunale les précisions de
mélanie poké et quentin le frère 7 avril
2015 grégory gary astier le maire de
maurepas ferme son centre aquatique pour
raisons de sécurité
la structure devrait renaître grâce à
une association avec one year et
elancourt on est trois communes touchées
vous savez
parce que aussi il n'y a pas eu
l'entretien nécessaire qui a été fait
auparavant
il ya quelques années donc bien sûr on
est trois communes fortement touché nos
enfants aussi
et bien sûr il faut accéder tout cela et
en même temps c'est bon aujourd'hui plus
difficile de trouver les moyens
une intercommunalité aidé par saint
quentin en yvelines la communauté
d'agglomération a débloqué 2,4 millions
d'euros pour le projet nous sommes
lancés dans la procédure de l'assistance
à maîtrise d ouvrage en concession avec
une délégation de service public pour la
gestion de ce futur équipement et sa
construction
donc nous avons délibéré les trois
villes pour lancer la démo qui va nous
aider à constituer le projet dans le
détail avant de lancer les appels
d'offres en concession c'est une
concession sur 25 ans nous allons
confier donc un délégataire est assez
risque également nous avons confiée à un
concessionnaire nous allons confier le
financement la maintenance de
l'établissement le fonctionnement de
l'établissement et les différentes
gestions qui peuvent concerner les
renouvellement d'équipements notamment
pendant la période des 25 ans de
concession
une concertation avec les habitants va
être lancée dans l'année la destruction
du bâtiment actuel devrait être
effective en 2019
l'une des actualités de la semaine
c'était aussi le froid qui s'est
largement installée en ile de france les
températures ont flirté avec les -10
degrés la nuit des conditions
climatiques difficiles après la neige et
les inondations du début d'année surtout
pour les plus démunis à
magny-les-hameaux une nouvelle
association la marche à suivre vient
d'être créé pour soutenir justement les
sans abri en leur apportant de la
nourriture et des vêtements
l lundi soir nous recevions certains de
ses membres
extraits l'objectif c'est de fournir de
s'organiser la semaine afin de fournir
tous les week-ends de la nourriture des
vêtements et est ce qu'on appelle des
kits d'hygiène aux sans abri sur paris
et notamment sur leucate les deux le
quartier de châtelet-les halles mai
donc ça ça s'organise sous forme de
package ou de kits donc dans ce kit on
essaye de fournir en fonction du temps
et des températures et des semaines donc
soit un plat chaud un plat froid avec
une bouteille d'eau que ce soit aussi un
jus de fruit ou un fruit ou une compote
un paquet de chips ou un paquet de
gâteaux avec cela on ajoute ce qu'on
appelle des kits d'hygiène
ça sera principalement des brosses à
dents des dentifrices des lingettes pour
se laver les mains le visage ou le corps
en général
et puis à côté de ça on essaye de faire
ça notamment parce qu'il fait froid en
ce moment donc à porter des gants des
bonnets des écharpes
on reçoit aussi tout autre type de don
vestimentaire comme des pulls des
pantalons etc
on a aussi fait quelques courses de ça
nous arrivait de faire quelques courses
se récupérer des plaids ou des couettes
avec les bénévoles
c'est la fin de ce set 8 l'hebdo retour
de l'actualité en direct lundi à 18h sur
l'antenne de tv 78 d'ici là restez
connectés et informés grâce à notre site
internet et nos réseaux sociaux
l'application tv
soixante dix huit bons ocana tous et à
la semaine prochaine
[Musique]